[Music]
hey what is up guys mkbhd here and this
is it this is the long-awaited samsung
galaxy note 8. it was unveiled today and
right off the bat you can see it's a
very familiar phone not just because it
was leaked everywhere but because it's
pretty much picking right up where the
note 7 left off last year before all of
its battery problems i'm gonna try not
to make any explosion jokes during this
entire video we'll see how i do but yeah
it's true so for some people it's boring
but to me and to many others it's pretty
exciting because this is the 2017
version of last year's phone which was
already really good and had a chance of
being my favorite phone last year before
the recall so there's a couple main
changes to note 8 that set it in place
for this year new display and design up
front new dual cameras around the back
some updated s pen features and new
specs that's the core of what's
happening here so the quickest place to
start would definitely be the specs
snapdragon 835 six gigs of ram 3300
milliamp hour battery and android 7.1
right out the box so write about what
you'd expect not the biggest battery in
the world since they're not pushing it
to the absolute limit but of course fast
charging and wireless charging are on
board for those who use it and then you
have the slightly updated design with
the new display up front it's a 6.3 inch
18 and a half by nine quad hd super
amoled display
and it just looks incredible you can see
it thin bezels of course since it's 2017
up top and on the bottom
and it has those slightly curved corners
of the display too like the s8 had but
yeah it's a huge display and it's a big
phone too don't get me wrong but of
course the thin bezels make it feel like
it fits in the same body size or same
footprint that's not really much bigger
at all than last year's phone it's crazy
how reasonable this phone makes a 6.3
inch display look but other design
changes yes this phone does now have a
bixby button i kind of saw that coming
from a mile away but they're doubling
down on it and maybe you know bixby's
improving getting software updates
getting better
and a lot of people are of course pretty
bummed by the fingerprint placement up
on the top of the back of the phone the
fingerprint reader and actually wasn't
that concerned with it when i was
playing with the phone but then i
remembered my hands aren't the same size
as everybody's so if you hand this phone
to someone with normal sized hands it
will definitely be a different
experience so i get it it would be way
more reachable somewhere else like the
middle of the back but then it would
also be i think way more ugly and i
think samsung has roped themselves into
putting it all the way up with the rest
of the back facing sensors there in that
rectangle kind of their own fault there
either way this phone has you know iris
scanning and facial recognition and some
other ways of securing your phone
biometrically if you just can't stand
that back facing fingerprint sensor the
s pen is also now improved since this is
a note so anyone who uses this will
definitely appreciate it the tip is
thinner that's like the number one thing
i noticed right away and it also has
even more levels of pressure sensitivity
and in the software they've made
improvements to all the stuff it works
with so like screen off notes and
actually the wheel that pops up when you
first take out the s pen i don't know if
you could do this with the last note but
you can spin it around and even add
whatever apps you want to that carousel
so it kind of acts like another quick
launch carousel which is pretty cool in
case you have a certain
other assistant you like to launch my
favorite new software feature though in
this note is actually being able to
launch two apps
at once in split screen with a single
touch so in apps edge you can create an
app pair
like say youtube and the browser for
example and touching it launches them
both side by side that's definitely
going to get me to use split screen a
bit more even as awesome as a huge
display like this is i found myself not
using split screen very much on previous
notes and samsung phones but i realized
like if you have this good setup like
this you just set up a couple of good
ones like spotify and google maps for
example a lot of music while driving
i'll definitely use that more often so i
can kind of dig into that but that's
pretty much it for new software stuff
happening if you've used an s8 or a note
7 you've seen this style this look
before there isn't a laundry list of new
features with the software here but
that's the way samsung goes so easily
the biggest new headlining feature new
change with the galaxy note 8 is the
cameras around the back so note 8 is now
rocking two 12 megapixel cameras on the
back one with a normal wide-angle lens
and the other with a telephoto lens a 2x
optical zoom just like iphone 7 plus
does but the difference with these
is they're both optically stabilized so
in theory it should work more often in
low light than the iphones in theory and
samsung's tossed in a couple pretty cool
features to work with the combo of
cameras as you'd expect so they have a
little 1x and 2x button now to switch
between the lenses that everyone's doing
i get it it's simple it works no
complaints but you can now see some new
photo modes including one called live
focus which is just like portrait mode
at first on the iphones so it moves to
the 2x telephoto lens and blurs
background but then you can change the
level of background blur
live as the name implies and see exactly
how much you want it blurred before you
take the picture so it's definitely
artificially adding blur and then once
you take the picture you can go into the
gallery but with these it also
simultaneously captures a photo
with the wide-angle lens and the
telephoto lens at the same time and you
can also now still adjust the level of
added background blur after you've taken
the photo which is pretty awesome so now
obviously i want to keep messing with
the camera to see how good this blur
effect actually is you know if it
handles edges well if there's a
difference in aperture between the
telephoto and wide angle lens so all
this stuff will be tested for the full
review but in summary i'm pretty
optimistic for this phone much of that
is obviously because samsung has a
pretty damn good track record with a lot
of this stuff a lot of times you get a
new phone coming out and you don't know
if you can be optimistic or not and this
note 8 is gonna be an expensive phone
coming in at around a thousand us
dollars retail when it drops on
september 15th so you really want to be
able to trust what it's going to do is
everything you want but like i said
samsung has this track record you know
they've had great cameras in their
phones in the past they've had a great
track record with displays they've had
the best display in any smartphone for
the past two three years
battery life has yet to be seen and
software updates are always a toss up
but as a package note 8 to me is looking
pretty damn hot so either way the full
review will tell off so definitely
subscribe to be the first to see that
when it comes out if you haven't already
but that's it let me know what you think
of galaxy note 8. thank you for watching
and i'll talk to you guys in the next
one
peace
[Music]